[Music]
hi good afternoon everybody I'm Ken
Goldberg and I'm a foreign asana and
thank you for joining us today it was
super exciting for us to see course
presenting the cloud services platform
today in his keynote we started working
on this vision a bit of a four years ago
where we took our years of experience in
developing applications and managing
them reliably and brought them to the
industry through kubernetes and
kubernetes engine we invited community
users partners and customers to work
with us
ensuring kubernetes solves real problems
for all users the result is that
kubernetes today is the industry
standard for managing containers
applications it is used by enterprises
of all sizes in their journey to
modernization increasing teams
productivity and leapfrogging
competition last year we open sourced
sto decoupling service development from
service management and it already got
significant traction from the industry
including first users in production
today we are bringing those technologies
and a few new ones together building an
integrated stack giving you application
modernization wherever you are in the
cloud and on-premises our new solution
is will be those four principles in mind
consistent experience centralized
control agility with reliability and
flexibility we'll be using them to
introduce our products it will help you
understand why we have built cloud
services platform the way we have and
what to expect next if they sound
familiar to you that is because they are
already rooted in kubernetes they're
also demonstrated in many other Google
cloud platform products and solutions
today you will hear more of them
throughout the next three days and we
want you to know that these principles
are not just principles for technical
design there are principles that enable
enable a customer
journey that starts with you where you
are and allows you to transform IT at
your own pace we all know that
enterprise IT is complex every customer
that I work with has a mix of custom
developed software as well as
off-the-shelf software and a variety of
on Prem hardware from many vendors and
across that they have to ensure security
regulatory compliance and all of their
policies work seamlessly this complexity
can slow businesses down in the middle
of this environment cloud offers an
opportunity for speed and competitive
advantage but without the right software
cloud can sometimes add another layer of
heterogeneity to an already complex
environment cloud services platform is
targeting the 80% of enterprises that
are looking to enable hybrid cloud today
they need a way to homogenize public
cloud infrastructure with what they have
on Prem connecting and managing it
together
I see users marrying the modern with the
existing so that they can really enable
use cases like these they want to have
CI CD continuous integration continuous
deployment across public and private and
they want to be able to manage compute
at the edge where they can have low
latency or for regulatory reasons or
just for business reasons and yet have
centralized intelligence in the cloud
and then lastly they want to be able to
consume the best of breed services
regardless of where they're running
whether in their on Prem data center in
GCP or in any cloud today to accomplish
these use cases requires a lot of
fragile do-it-yourself integration or it
can result in a compromise between
consistency and choice between agility
and reliability
cloud service platform is a different
kind of hybrid cloud software that
overcomes some of these trade-offs so
you don't have to make those compromises
at its core cloud services platform is
powered by kubernetes and sto which are
open source enabling that consistency
across environment but on top of that
this stack is custom configured
Enterprise hardened tested and managed
by Google so you have that centralized
control it is also deeply integrated
with DCP services to deliver the
benefits of Google cloud on Prem and
then this integration enables a wide
variety of solutions such as CI CD
across clouds also machine learning and
Cerberus and a variety of others today
hen and I are going to demo for you
exactly how we break some of the
traditional trade offs with these design
principles the first principle of cloud
services platform is consistent
experience we have seen with kubernetes
how much consistency matter the idea of
write once run anywhere pulled users and
partners into its community no login to
a specific platform really excites users
it simplifies things for developers and
operation teams when they know there is
a set of certain set of primitives they
can rely on cloud services platform
takes consistency further portability
isn't enough users are looking for
consistent user experience use the same
tools everywhere where there were close
run their operation teams would like to
have the same way to manage the cluster
on-premise and in the cloud developers
would like to develop build and deploy
the application the same way regardless
of where the workloads will run the SRA
team would like to have the same tools
in order to troubleshoot an issue
regardless of an environment
our customers tell us they want a
consistent experience of kubernetes
engine g ke g key has been GA for almost
three years now and users like
kubernetes engine automation upstream
currency and availability it is Google
configured managed and supported
kubernetes they've been asking us how
can they get the same capabilities in
their own Prem data centers and we're
giving our customers exactly that
introducing GK on Prem it is Google
configured kubernetes with automated
provisioning managed upgrades and
security in your on-prem environment
when talking with users this is when
their eyes light up the idea that they
don't have to train their teams once or
twice to learn different tool really
excites them this is where they're
spending most of their time operation
teams having a single playbook to manage
all of their environments is really a
game changer for them less time spent on
training and integration leaves more
time to innovation and increases the
team productivity what's even more
awesome about GK on Prem that it
connects seamlessly to Google cloud
platform and helps you manage a multi
cluster environment wherever your
cluster is and all of them we look and
behave exactly the same let's move
through the demo and see consistency in
action ok so here what we have already
is that earlier this morning my team
provision a GK on Prem cluster on this
pizza box server running vSphere well
this is a live demo and now we'll show
you how to integrate this cluster into
your GK environment and get that
consistent experience from the G key UI
I can go and register an external
cluster I will call it the innovative
name West
and then I will download this gke
Connect manifest let's look inside it
what it will help us is to create that
connection to GCP
so what it has inside it has a namespace
and in addition to that there is a
service account and roll bindings we
will use in the UI in order to access
and view the workloads in the cluster we
also have here a deployment of the gke
Connect agent which is what we use in
order to create a secure connection from
this cluster into GCP let's apply it you
can also see here in this UI the GK is
waiting for gke Connect connection with
Google and once it's done we will see
this change into a checkmark yay and
we'll continue to the next step here I
have to provide some old details also I
want to make sure that we are talking
with the right cluster from GCP side so
I will use a certificate provide the IP
and continue to authenticate for this
set of the demo I will just skip
authentication for now
but I can also use a user token or
leverage an identity provider in order
to do basic authentication and we are
finished what we can see right now in
the environment in my GK environment I
can see all my clusters including this
on Prem cluster and it is already
registered but you can also see that I
don't have any details about it
everybody needs to enter their own user
credentials and this is why there is
this lock icon here this is good hygiene
practice in general and this will help
us to maintain the integrity of the
environment and make sure that we have
the right audit logging and our buck
policies
I will copy it from the environment
and now I will actually get access into
the cluster and you can see how I can
see the cluster size the number of CPU
and more from this point on everything
actually behaves exactly the same as the
gke clusters you are used to managing on
gku i yes first live demo yay we see the
master version for example which is very
important again another attribute that
we keep consistent with your GK
environment we heard from our customers
this is really important for them for
the integration aspect I have two gk8
two kubernetes we can see the nodes that
are there and like every other GE a
cluster I can go into the node and see
really useful information such as the
pods running and resources available on
that node so this is just looking on a
single cluster but then Jiki actually
creates this multi cluster single pane
of glass where I can see for example all
the workloads running in my environment
regardless of which cluster they are
running on and this is true also for
services as well so this is really nice
getting that visibility into my
environment but what's even more awesome
and again first I'm doing it on stage I
will also deploy from GCP for the first
time into a cluster which is actually
not a GCP cluster and it can run
anywhere will go in to deploy and we
really want to make sure it's simple as
possible and all I need to do is to
choose the right cluster I will click
deploy and what do you think Tom Tom Tom
what uh yay
and while it's merely look simple it's
actually not simple to do and it for us
we heard from our customers that they
really appreciate the management
capabilities they have on gke and we
want to provide that wherever customers
are running their workloads back to the
slides
this is a quarter I really like since
it's quick captures really what excites
me the most about the technology we are
building you know I'm an infrastructure
person but what excites me is that we
are allowing developers to really free
their time and focus on innovation
awesome consistency is the building
block for the next principle of cloud
services platform which is centralized
control we all know that control is
important but what is different about
cloud services platform is two things
number one it provides control not just
across clusters but across environments
so across GCP and other environments
number two it works out of the box with
your existing authentication and other
services so it doesn't create a
trade-off between control and agility as
a complement to hen's announcement about
gk on prem we're also really excited to
announce gke policy manager which is an
alpha now this is a piece of soft piece
of software that allows admins to define
tenant name spaces as well as policies
that can be applied across environments
and these are defined in a single source
of truth which could be G CPI M or a git
repository the software then
automatically updates all participating
clusters at once regardless of where
they are they could be anticipate or a
different cloud or on Prem
and so it synchronizes those policies
everywhere our first version supports
synchronizes synchronizing namespaces
role based access control or are back
policies quota policies and more and
we're going to show you a demo of that
now actually using the cluster that hand
provisioned
so we can move to the demo screen
all right so first I want to show you
what clusters I have access to here I've
got actually four clusters I'm going to
be using three of them in this demo I've
got us Central East Coast and this puppy
over here the West cluster I've also set
up some watches on these three clusters
so here's a watch on East here's a watch
on Central and here's a watch on the
namespaces in West and as you can see
there's really just system namespaces
here today as an admin what I want to do
is across all of my environments I want
to set a set of policies that apply to
all of them and I've created some
policies first of all then I'm gonna
copy into this directory and let me show
you what they are
so I want each cluster to have three
namespaces a dev namespace a prod
namespace and a staging namespace and
for my Ansari's I want to give them pod
creation access across all of these
three namespaces so I've created a pod
creator sre role binding that in this
hierarchical tree applies to all three
of these namespaces but in my dev
namespace that's the only place that I
want to allow developers to create pods
I don't want them to be able to create
prog pods in production or in staging so
I want I have created this role and role
binding for pod creator pod creation
just for the devs just in the dev
namespace also I want to make sure that
my test costs don't balloon out of
control so I'm going to set a quota
policy which is encapsulated here in
coda llamó also for the dev space
alright this is cool
now what I'm going to do is add that to
an empty git repository so that's gonna
be my single source of truth for all of
my policies and then I will go ahead and
commit this file and as I push this
change you will start to see in these
three watches those three namespaces
come up so we should see and orders dev
orders prod and order staging namespace
come up in all three clusters fingers
crossed and okay it
like us Central has got orders Dave
Prodan staging nice and us East does as
well and here is our is our pet cluster
here on Prem and on the stage which has
gke connect the agent that Han
configured earlier and there also we
have the three namespaces
so you see here our centralized policy
management synchronized across multiple
environments one last thing I'm going to
show you is that quota that I created I
want to make sure that it's also
actually enforced right here in this
cluster so I've changed context to the
West cluster and I'm gonna see if
there's a quota file so let's go ahead
and open that and indeed there is a
resource quota file and it does set a
both CPU and memory quota limit for what
my devs can do and so that's it that
concludes the demo
in summary cloud services platform
policy management software allows you to
apply policies across cloud from one
source of truth you can kind of think of
it as security and policy portability
that was an awesome demo one of my
highlights the thing I love the most
about this announcement the combination
of consistent experience and centralized
control access on-premise in the cloud
is powerful but all of this is
ultimately in the service of your
business success that depends directly
on developers productivity and on their
apps running reliably often these two
things are at odds developers want to
move fast but operation teams would like
to make sure the environments are
Enterprise ready and they would like to
have less changes that brings us to the
third principle of cloud services
platform agility with reliability cloud
services platform lifts this trade-off
with easier if CEO is an open platform
to connect secure and managed services
it takes care of traffic management
monitoring and security it does it by
raising the level of abstractions from
VMs containers
and ports to services this also means
that sto can work with uncontained
workloads together with containerized
ones this week we are announcing is tier
1.0 and its readiness for production
environment this has two big benefits
one it puts more intelligence in the
hands of the operators who can now
systematically monitor secure and
control services the second one it
relieves the developers from writing
common capabilities that every act
requires like monitoring authentication
logging and more by decoupling
development from operation easier gives
coders their time back while not
compromising the availability aspects
and give operations high quality common
services enabling greater visibility
security and reliability now we'll go to
the last demo for today all right so as
a developer I want to focus on writing
my applications that actually add value
to my business I don't really want to
write a whole bunch of common services
for off their monitoring or logging or
other things and those things need to be
done in they're done well in their own
right so if co actually enables us to
decouple that work from developers
freeing us to focus on what's important
and I'm gonna demo that for you
specifically this demo is gonna show you
three things number one it's an example
of how SEO frees developers from having
to implement off in each of their
services number two it's going to show
you how as a security operator I can
apply policy incrementally to new
services in the face of existing
services without breaking them and then
number three I'm going to demo how SEO
enables a secure by default enterprise
and to do that I'm going to be using
this application called the book info
demo app it consists of four services as
you can see these four services are
written in four different languages also
referred to as a poly
application in each of these languages
can have their own way of implementing
monitoring or auth or any of these
services but what we've done here is
we've deployed sto and we've we've
enabled sto as an auto injected on by
proxy in each service and you kind of
see that with the blue line this
required zero code changes from any of
the developers and out of the box it
comes with authentication best-in-class
authentication it comes with intelligent
routing and telemetry for demo purposes
we also have two clients there's a
modern client that's in the book info
namespace so that's gonna be shown in
green and it's actually going to get all
of the changes that we make through ISTE
oh and then there's a red client which
is a legacy legacy client it could be a
legacy service that you have existing
and it's not going to be Asti unable and
then what we're going to show here is
incremental enablement of M TLS in first
in permissive mode and then in strict
mode all right so we can move over to my
screen so we can start the demo
okay okay so for this demo I'm going to
use the Midwest cluster and so we've
switched contacts to the Midwest cluster
and just to show you what's in this
cluster these are the namespaces so sto
is in fact deployed in the Midwest
cluster and also we have the book info
application which we were showing you
just on the screen but let's take a look
to make sure what the deployments are
part of book info and so here you see
there's a client which is the book info
client that's going to be generating
load there is the there are the for
services the details service the product
page service the rating service and
three versions of the review service so
we can do canary and so what we're going
to do is the book info client is going
to be hitting the product page but
remember I told you there's also a
legacy client so let's just take a look
at where that is if we just do cube cut'
I'll get deployments there's this legacy
client that's not part of the sto or
book info namespace and it's also going
to be hitting the product page let's
first make just check to make sure
there's no policies installed and so
let's see if there's any policies
there's no policies and let's also then
get a graph on a dashboard so that we
can take a look at the traffic that's
hitting the product page and so this is
the the IP address for the graph on a
dashboard and I've already gone ahead
and set that up so here you see that
there's two QPS of traffic hitting the
product page so here we are we're
looking at the history of service
dashboard in graph on ax and we're
looking at what's hitting the product
page and at the moment there's two QPS
of traffic and it's all non-authentic
ated so there's no client side
authentication anybody that hits the
product page will get a response and you
know it's all to hundreds so now what
we're gonna do is we're gonna turn on
permissive m TLS in the book info
namespace so what that means is I'm
gonna set up this policy and then apply
it let's take a look at the policy so
the policy is going to apply to every
service in the book info namespace and
the mode is permissive and it's your
mutual so permissive mode means that
whether the client that's hitting is it
has mutant MPLS enabled or not book the
product page is going to go ahead and
accept that traffic and so what we
should see though in Griffin ax is some
of the traffic is going to be M TLS some
of the traffic is not going to be M TLS
because we've turned on M TLS for all
services in the book info namespace okay
so now let's go ahead and apply this
policy and it looks like the policy is
created the destination rule is created
and now when we look at Gravano we'll
see one Q pious of M TLS traffic from
that load generator that that book info
client that's in book info namespace
that has sto and then one QP s of
traffic from the legacy client that
doesn't have m TLS okay so let's see
what happened and indeed you see that
the non M TLS traffic has gone down to
one QP s so this is just the traffic
from the legacy client and in addition
we've now got this additional traffic
that's also one QP s that is M TLS so
this is the M TLS traffic from the book
info client that's in the in the same
namespace so you see we've gone down
from q2 QP s to one QP s one QP s each
of em TLS and non-empty LS so this is
permissive mode that's great and the
benefit here was you know we didn't
break the legacy service so the legacy
service is still hitting the product
page and that's fine and s re can then
talk to the developers and say hey we
got a stop with this legacy service
please implement client side off and
that legacy service because we want
everything to be authenticated because
this is a product page that's you know
it's got sensitive information so now
what we're gonna do is you know we want
to turn off the legacy service turns out
it's actually rogue and we want to
enable MTL s only authentication we only
want services that have client-side
authentication to communicate with our
product and product info page so this is
what the Yamma looks like it's very
similar so it again applies to the book
info namespace but now the mode is
strict
so we're strictly going to accept
traffic from services
client services that understand M TLS
and so let's go ahead and apply that and
here we go
and so now that policy has been applied
and what we should see now is only one
QP s of traffic only from the service
that's in the book info namespace that
has m TLS enabled and the other one the
road client should go away so let's see
did that happen and it looks like it did
happen so you see that the blue service
the traffic from the unauthenticated non
M TLS service has gone down to zero QP s
and now we only just have the one QP s
of traffic from the M TLS enabled
service and we can see that together so
actually if you want we can see the
history of this let's just go back 15
minutes and you'll see we had both two
QP s then we went to one and one and now
we just have one so that's nice in
summary you know without any code
changes we have enabled client side
authentication across every service in
the book info namespace and also by the
way we've turned on security by default
so that if there are any other services
in the future created in book info
they're going to be M T and s and M TLS
enabled as well those are not the only
benefits of s do we don't really have
time to demo all of the benefits today
so instead I've invited a customer to
speak to you about how they are using
cloud services platform to solve real
world challenges it's my pleasure and
please well please join me in welcoming
Jeff white platform architect at eBay to
the stage
thank you hi Jeff thank you welcome
thank you for joining us that GCP next
can you tell us a little bit more about
your group and your role at eBay hi I'm
excited to be here and share eBay story
my group is focused on building products
to expand eBay's reach to new markets
and market segments last year we
released a new buying experience for the
Chinese market we also released eBay on
Google assistant and we've been
developing AI technology to enhance
these products my role is to help build
our services platform our team is
responsible for all aspects of
development and operations everything
from choosing application frameworks
continuous integration and continuous
delivery platforms and setting standards
for logging monitoring and alerting one
of our goals is to build a services
platform that is easy to evolve as our
architecture grows and matures and
places minimal burden on individual
developers a core strategy to delivering
on our product and technology goals was
our decision to expand to the public
cloud two and a half years ago there
were many benefits to expanding to the
public cloud the key aspects that were
important for us were global
infrastructure auto scaling and managed
services these aspects have helped us
quickly build new products scale our
infrastructure with our user traffic and
provide an optimized experience to our
international customers that's great and
if I understand correctly you now have
more than 30 DCP services that your
using yes pretty much we take advantage
of GCP services as much as we can and we
try to place all our applications in
kubernetes Wow that sounds like an
amazing charter Jeff so how's your
journey so far fantastic we've learned a
tremendous amount about building robust
cloud native services kubernetes and
helm along with our internal tools and
standards have made it very easy to
deploy services and we've scaled our
architecture across multiple dimensions
we have on the order of 100 applications
and they are running a variety of
languages and frameworks and these
services are deployed across multiple
clusters running around the world
Wow and of course we've scaled our
infrastructure horizontally to match our
traffic and workloads but scaling across
these dimensions presents new monitoring
challenges a micro services architecture
shifts the emphasis from monitoring
individual services in isolation to
monitoring the entire system as a whole
when you get paged the problem is never
your fault right right it's always you
can't connect to one of your
dependencies or some error way upstream
has propagated all the way to you and
now everyone is up trying to figure out
the root cause
standardizing monitoring signals allows
us to monitor across the system this
allows you to do things like correlate
logs by trace ID
and distributed tracing so you can
inspect the network call stack but these
monitoring concepts require services to
collaborate on consistent standards and
they become part of the platform itself
but adding this logic to our
applications and libraries makes it
difficult to migrate especially in a
polyglot environment maintaining a
services platform becomes exponentially
difficult as the architecture scales I
see I understand so how are you dealing
with this complexity and multi polyglot
services environment boom
so we looked at service mesh technology
and we saw the value of moving these
common networking concerns from our
application processes to an individual
independent component and we
particularly like how sto makes this
transparent to services with its strong
kubernetes integration and sidecar proxy
approach so we started experimenting is
with Sto earlier this year and it was a
natural decision to initially focus on
the observability features metrics
traces and logs these provided us with
the biggest initial benefit while
minimizing risk and learning curve and
perhaps most importantly we would be
able to use the very metrics provided by
sto to help us evaluate and fine-tune as
we incorporate more advanced sto
features as part of our testing we
gradually increase the size of our mesh
by using an opt in policy and today we
are running sto in production that's
awesome
[Applause]
our mesh contains about 10 services so
far and we are progressively adding more
and we now have a uniform and
transparent mechanism of collecting
metrics traces and logs the Prometheus
and Griffin dashboards provide us with
the key metrics we can get an aggregated
view of the overall health of the entire
service mesh showing traffic latency and
errors
three of the four golden monitoring
signals and we can dive into an
individual application and see those
same very metrics and we also have
stackdriver integration working and
we're continuing to explore those
capabilities these tools complement our
existing metrics and monitoring allow us
to continue to refine our service level
objectives and assist us in
troubleshooting live site issues and
we're now in a great position to start
introducing some of the more advanced
sto features we look forward to seeing
how much amidst EO simplifies our
monitoring and improves our system
performance wow this is awesome to hear
thank you Jeff it was such a great time
to work with you and the team over the
past few years a few months as we
continue and work on SDO is there any
feedback or requests for us so take it
back to the team sure the kubernetes
integration is excellent the helm charts
make the installation a simple one-liner
the automatic sidecar injection provides
a transparent way to attach the client
proxy and the default graph on a
dashboards provide a great starting
point for monitoring the critical
signals of the system in terms of areas
of improvement we look forward to
getting access to more granular data and
for example we would love to be able to
slice and dice our metrics by URL we
also like to see sto expose more
sophisticated retry and timeout
configuration settings and of course we
look forward to a managed sto service
thank you very much thank you thank you
thank you luckily we have all of that
record it so we won't forget that so we
started with the friends prints up the
first principle consistent experience
consistent experience is often a traded
with flexibility when you lock things
down to make them consistent you limit
your options as an example when you you
cannot take a Best of Breed approach
when you decide to standardize we also
heard Jeff talks about the need of
having a platform that evolves as our
requirements continue to change cloud
services platform breaks this trade off
with a fourth design principle
flexibility clouds of this platform is
build an extensible open software it
comes with an ecosystem and applicable
architecture that gives you flexibility
a choice of solution and the ability to
integrate into them without introducing
introducing friction in the user
experience if something is missing you
can fill the gap yourself without
compromising consistency the platform
allows you to evolve as your needs and
requirements change we are leveraging
kubernetes and is tío extensibility and
a rich ecosystem so you can customize
evolve and integrate cloud services
platform to better fit your needs with
that I'm super excited to share that we
are the first major cloud provider to
offer a production ready commercial
kubernetes application in the GCP
marketplace
it is developed by third party partners
our commercial kubernetes up support
usage based billing simplified licensing
and easy deployment to kubernetes engine
on TCP and everywhere else my favorite
part about this announcement is that all
kubernetes are listed in the marketplace
I'll Google vetted that includes
vulnerability scanning and partner
agreements from maintenance and support
this brings the open cloud services
platform ecosystem to you wherever you
are
clouds of this platform is a unique
hybrid offering that it dresses today's
enterprise challenges where you are in
the cloud and on-premises in the session
today we focus on the core platform
services we introduce the new GK on Prem
and how it is consistent with kubernetes
engine the new GK policy management is
here together with strike driver and the
marketplace gives you tools and is a way
to manage this multi cluster environment
the key principles of consistent
experience centralized control agility
with reliability and flexibility have
stood the test of time at Google and now
with cloud services platform we are
making sure that they support you
through your journey without the need to
compromise between them we will continue
in bringing more solutions and prod
products into the cloud services
platform based on our years of
experience following the same principles
Google Cloud is the only public cloud
provider bringing consistency
flexibility control and speed of the
cloud to your local data centers along
with the freedom of workout portability
to the environment of your choice we are
very happy to bring the cloud Google's
cloud to you
[Applause]
thank you very much for joining us today
and thank you so much deaf for talking
about your use case and your environment
we hope that we've managed to pique your
interest in cloud services platform
there's a lot more we didn't have time
to cover everything these are some deep
dives tomorrow and on Thursday that we
would highly recommend you visit for a
deep dive on sto on GK on Prem and of
course hybrid use cases thank you thank
you
[Music]